With its flare for nudity, murder, incest
and so much more; Game of Thrones is not a
TV show that is known for its lightheartedness.
Still the show runners do like to toss in
a few Easter Eggs throughout the show for
their viewers to enjoy.
With the shows passionate fan base, even a
subtle reference has been discovered and talked
about.
Make sure to give us a like as we reveal an
Easter Egg you didn’t know about in your
favorite show with Dragons.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Incredible
Easter Eggs Hidden In Game of Thrones
“Dragonslayer” Dragon
Disney’s 1981 film, Dragonslayer is about
a young “wizarding” apprentice that’s
sent to kill a dragon who has a taste for
eating young girls.
That plot line could even work in Game of
Thrones, and maybe that’s why the writer
George R.R. Martin mentioned his favorite
fantasy film character in season one.
When Daenerys’ annoying brother Viserys
tried to impress Doreah, he told her the names
all of the dragon skulls that were once kept
in the Red Keep.
One is named Vermithrax, the dragon from Dragonslayer.
President George W. Bush’s Head
Game of Thrones is one of the most expensive
shows on television, each episode in season
six cost upwards of 10 million dollars; so
finding ways to save costs are essential to
the show runners.
In season one when Joffrey Baratheon forces
Sansa Stark to look at her father’s head
on a spike you can see president George W.
Bush’s head.
The show runners insisted that it was not
a political statement but just a way to reuse
props.
Still HBO released an apology and vowed to
remove the head from future releases.
Tyrion’s Nose
At the end of Season two, Tyrion Lannister
is attacked by Ser Mandon and slashed across
his face leaving a scare.
Before Tyrion can be killed, his squire, Podrick
Payne kills Ser Mandon saving the fan favorite
character.
After he heals Tyrion’s sister, Cersei tells
him that she wanted to see his face because
she was told he had lost his nose.
This is a reference to the books where Tyrion
had lost his nose but in the show it was more
cost effective for them just to give him a
scar.
It works for us!
Gandalf's Blade
The War of the Five Kings is the civil war
that exploded after King Robert died and everyone
wanted a seat on the Iron Throne.
With all of these kings fighting we wonder
if any of them notice the swords on the chair.
One bears a striking resemblance to Gandalf's
blade, Glamdring from Lord of the Rings while
another one looks like Orlando Bloom’s sword
from the film Kingdom of Heaven.
Was this done as homage or just another way
to save production costs by reusing props?
Peter Dinklage's Ghost
We don’t mean his spiritual ghost but the
Ghost that Peter Dinklage voiced for the video
game Destiny.
Dinklage was fired as the voice of the Ghost
due to his “boring narration” and replaced
by Nolan North.
In a scene from Game of Thrones there is a
window behind Dinklage that holds a strong
resemblance to the ghost shape.
No one involved in the show has verified this
but it sure does look very familiar.
Was this a Destiny Easter Egg?
Or just a fancy window design?
Let us know what you think in the comments.
The Title Sequence
It is easy to ignore or fast forward through
the opening credits because it appears to
be the same each time.
If you actually watch it, you can see it is
not the same.
That’s because the show is displaying the
different lands that we are going to visit
in that episode.
If Tyrion is in Kings Landing at the last
5 seconds of the episode we will see Kings
Landing in the opening title sequence.
Put down the remote and take a look next time.
R+L=J
One of the most popular fan theories for Game
of Thrones has to do with the parents of Jon
Snow.
This theory believes that Jon Snow is not
Ned Stark's son, but is the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Ned's sister Lyanna.
The show runners knew how popular this theory
was and decided to add an Easter Egg in the
first season referencing it.
You can see a “RL” carved out on a wall
right next to Jon Snow.
Maybe they are telling us something.
Jon Snow’s Hobbit Friends
Speaking of Jon Snow did you know his friends
were named after another famous book series?
George R.R. Martin is a fan of The Lord of
the Rings books and has read them through
and through numerous times.
He has also admitted to pulling inspiration
from the books as he wrote his stories.
Jon Snow’s best friends at The Wall are
named Sam and Pyp (pronounced Pip).
Do these names sound familiar to your little
hobbit ears?
Littlefinger Predicts Death
Petyr Baelish, aka Littlefinger keeps surprising
us in every season, whether he is betraying
Ned Stark or getting closer to the throne.
In season four he predicts the death of three
characters and on top of that in the order
he states them.
He says to young Robin Arryn that, “people
die at their dinner tables, they die in their
beds, they die squatting over their chamber
pots.”
These words clearly foreshadow the deaths
of Joffrey, Shae, and Tywin, who died at a
dinner table, in a bed, and on the toilet,
respectively.
Daenerys’ Champion Insulted with Monty Python
Joke
In the scene where the Meereenese rider challenged
Daenerys’ champion he shouts at them.
Nathalie Emmanuel translates the insults that
the rider barks and he even pees in Daenerys’
general direction.
According to the shows linguist David J. Peterson,
he is actually shouting insults from Monty
Python and the Holy Grail including, “Your
mother was a hamster.”
If you caught that one, you better be looking
for a job as a linguist because only the producer
and Peterson knew what they were doing since
the language is made up for the show.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any of your favorite Easter
eggs from Game of Thrones?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos!
Thanks for watching!